Russia has inflicted a year of tragedy
and Terror
on Ukraine
but the people of Ukraine have inspired
the world
we deeply admire the resilience of the
Ukrainian people
and their determination to defend their
territory
their sovereignty and their freedom
and nations of Goodwill have rallied
together to reject Putin's vision
of world chaos
of a world of chaos where tyrants can
trample borders and Conquer their
peaceful neighbors and break the rules
of War
and that's what this contact group
represents
together we have made clear that we will
support Ukraine's self-defense for the
Long Haul
and we will move out with the urgency
that the moment demands
earlier this month the United States
announced another round of security
assistance for Ukraine
the presidential drawdown announcement
included more ammunition for high Mars
it included 190 heavy heavy machine guns
to counter unmanned aerial systems from
Russia or or Iran
181 mrap vehicles in more than 2 000
anti-tank Munitions and other key
capabilities
we also added
1.75 billion dollars in Ukraine security
assistance initiative funds
for critical air defense capabilities
including
counter uas uas systems and more
and at today's contact group we joined
again with our valued allies and
partners
to make sure that Ukraine has what it
needs
when it needs it